hi everybody welcome I'm Lea and I'm
delighted to be returning here to
Strange Loop for the third time just out
of curiosity where any of you at my talk
two years ago about knitting a couple of
you oh that's exciting all right forget
everything you learned there because
knitting is totally different from
weaving so there's if there's one
takeaway I want you to get from this
talk knitting is totally different from
weaving which of course brings up the
question what is weaving in addition to
being this guy hugo weaving weaving is
one of the ways we have of turning a
yarn into a fabric and it is in fact one
of our oldest technologies wikipedia
claims wikipedia claims means take this
with a grain of salt but wikipedia
claims that there are some indications
that waving is weaving is Paleolithic
technology and there's definite evidence
of it as Neolithic technology so to be
clear that makes actual weaving
appreciably older than hugo weaving even
very generously interpreted the point is
that this is very old technology and
it's not quite as old as felting because
felting will happen by accident if
you're not careful but it's been around
for a very very long time and I
personally find that very exciting
because it means that there have been
countless ly many extremely smart people
throughout the entire world throughout
history and prehistory that have
invented subtly different weaving
techniques so there's pretty much
infinite sub sub sub sub domain
knowledge you could have about weaving
which is exciting to me because you know
if you're ever having one of these days
where you feel like you know everything
I don't have these days but maybe you do
if you're feeling bored you can just
pick up weaving and there's infinite to
know but what all of these ranches have
in common is that they involve interlace
meant so some set of yarns is crossing
over and under some other set of yarns
in particularly the kind of weaving I'm
talking about today there are two sets
of yarns so there's one set running the
whole length of the fabric which is what
we call the warp and there's another
thread or a set of threads that's
crossing back and forth to interlace
with it and that's called the weft a lot
of people have trouble to remember the
difference between these terms it may
help to remember that West is just an
archaic path
tensive we've so the wefts is the one
that was waved into into the warp this
particular swatch represents the very
most basic possible we have structure
which is called plain weave in which the
vertical and horizontal strands are just
alternating which one is on top and a
perfect trek checkerboard right so at
this crossing the weft is on top and on
all of its neighbors the warp is on top
we can even collapse these threads
together for a slightly more compact
notation that looks like this and this
is the notation I'm gonna be using
throughout the talk to represent a
fabric something to note is the
inherently binary nature of this
structure at a given interlace may point
either the warp is on top or the West is
on top and I'm guessing that some of you
may be perking up at the use of the word
binary here because you know why the
binary nature of weaving is important
sort of to this audience in particular
and I will get back to that in a couple
of slides I promise so okay so this is a
woven thing how did we get here
we likely used a tool called a loom what
even is a loom good question
a loom is any device which can hold the
warp threads so the long ones running
the length of the fabric at a reasonable
tension and ideally it will help us make
that interlace mentality z ER so maybe
some of you have met one of these before
show of hands out of curiosity it's I've
found that it's kind of gendered but a
lot of you may be seen one of these at
it at a summer camp and what happens is
you string up some loops top to bottom
on that and then you go in with that
sort of little metal hook and you go
over and under and over or under and
then you pull another loop across to
interlace with the other ones which is a
really good way to keep kids busy at
summer camp and if you for example
wanted to kill 20 years as your husband
straggles back from the Trojan War this
is also like a really good way to get
weaving done but if you actually want to
be weaving yards and yards of fabric it
is not practical to have to go over and
under and over and under every single
one so what most looms do is they give
you some way of forming a shed a shed is
an area formed when some but not all of
the work threads have been lifted up
so this is magical because it means that
when you pass the west thread straight
through in a straight shot it's going to
be over some of them and under some of
the other ones and this is one of those
concepts that is simultaneously
extremely basic and extremely magical I
think because you're doing this very
simple mechanical motion subsetting some
threads and then doing a very another
simple mechanical motion to interlace
them together the basic mechanism that
that does this that forms this shed is
called a Hetal and it's simply a little
hole that the work threads go through so
if the heddle goes up the warp thread
that is associated with that Hetal will
also go up this is a very basic kind of
loom still in which the odd-numbered
threads are each going through a petal
and in this particular case the evens
actually are going through a space
between the hetal's which you can kind
of think as its self petals I guess this
is enough to accomplish the plain weave
because you can lift up the whole Hetal
frame to bring the odds above the evens
and you can push it down to bring the
evens above the odds so you have a small
rigid mechanism that can separate the
warp into two subsets which is enough
for the plain weave but you can't do a
weave structure that's more complicated
than that plain weave without having to
do some manual interlacing in this
picture they have done that with that
green yarn on the other end of the Loom
control spectrum is these jacquard loom
which looks like this and which by the
way was not invented by jacquard it was
invented by a bunch of people including
Bhushan Falcone and Wisconsin some of
you have heard of this buddy before and
it's what I was referring to when I said
that the binary nature of weaving it's
historically interesting to computer
people that's because there's a card
loom in particular has a mechanism in
which every single warp thread can be
lifted can be controlled by a program
encoded as a punched card right so
that's notable to us because this idea
of encoding binary data on a punched
card would go on to inspire lots of
early data storage and early computing
history it's really cool it's also super
not relevant to us today this is not a
talk about jacquard looms somewhere
between that little rigid Hetal loom
with its two subsets odds and evens
that fully individualized Hetal control
of a jacquard loom is a loom like this
which is a four shaft floor loom for
hand weaving so this is a this
particular loom is a modern sort of
mid-range floor loom of the kind you
might buy to weave scarves or table
runners in your house this particular
model I think would run you about five
hundred dollars when I say that it is a
four shaft loom what I mean is that
there are four Hetal subsets defined by
these wooden frames across the top so
each warp goes through a Hetal
associated with just one of the frames
and it goes between the petals on all
the other three frames and to use this
loom you would sit in front of it and
you would press a pedal to raise up some
of the shafts so I also sorry I'm saying
shafts and frames interchangeably
they're in this context they are
interchangeable so shaft means frame and
frame mean shaft so you sit in front of
it you press a pedal and you're gonna
raise some shafts but wait a minute
there are 11 pedals why are there so
many pedals there's only four frames it
turns out that this is actually
configurable there's any one of these
pedals can be tied to any subset of the
frames this mapping is called the tie up
and it is an important creative tool for
the weaver and talking about sort of the
tie up and why it's an important
creative tool for the weaver is the
premise of the rest of this talk so
first we're going to go into a little
side tangent about the notational system
that hand weavers use this anotation
system is called a draught so in the
bottom left corner you see a woven
interlacing just like the same notation
I showed you before this one is slightly
more complicated than a plain weave it's
still considered very basic it's called
a twill weave so the basic concept where
the twill weave is that in this case
you've got the weft going over two warps
then under two warps then over two warps
etc in the next row down it's still
going over two under two but the whole
thing has shifted by one from the
previous row and because it's over to
under 2 this is called a 2 by 2 twill
weave the part at the top left is called
the threading this threading
representation is showing us which
thread is associated with which Hetal
frame so in this particular threading
that
leftmost warp its passing through a
Hetal in the fourth frame so whenever
the fourth frame is lifted that leftmost
warp will go up with it as will the
fifth 9th and 13th warps as well so this
is something I just want to take a
moment to emphasize again we're talking
about physical things and threading a
loom is actually kind of a pain to do
because you have to have to measure out
a bunch of warp threads you want them to
all be the same length you want them to
all be the same tension you don't want
them to be inter tangling with each
other and then you have to pull every
single one of them through a little hole
so this threading is something that you
probably only want to do once per fairly
long piece of fabric keep that in mind
on the bottom right we have the trebling
and for our purposes again treadle and
petal are synonyms so the traveling is
simply which petal you're pushing down
at any sort of time step along the
sequence of weaving so each row
corresponds to one raising of the warp
putting the weft through and then
letting the work back down in it so in
this case of course the first row and
you're going to be pushing down on the
leftmost petal and then the second from
left etcetera one two three four so if
you push the leftmost petal which warp
threads are raised those of you who are
thinking well that depends on the tiya
have been following along very well with
the talk so far and you're absolutely
correct the tie-up defines that mapping
between a petal and some number of petal
frames so in this case the leftmost
petal is tied to the back two frames to
find the warps that will be raised
we simply read up we can trace up to see
which frames are going to be selected by
that petal trace over to the Associated
warps and then draw them down into the
representation of the fabric and we
would of course continue drawing in the
rest of the fabric the same way to get
the full interlace Minh so I was talking
about this notation with a friend of
mine saying oh this is really cute
little sort of compact notation for
talking about mechanically what happens
when you're weaving and my friend was
like oh yeah weaving drafts those are
just matrix multiplication
and I was like yeah no I have no idea
what you're talking about it I've never
multiplied a matrix in my life so okay
and unfortunately when you google for
weaving matrix and multiplication you
get this picture which is completely
unhelpful but but fortunately at the
same time I was actually taking a
machine learning class and Amba
fortunately at the same time I was
taking machine learning in class so
shortly thereafter I had reason to watch
this completely amazing youtube series
by Grant Sanderson so this is three blue
one Brown if any of you want to learn
about matrices or like learned about
matrices but kind of hate them if you
want to stop hating them this is some
really good YouTube content right here
and he talked a lot about what you know
what it means to multiply a matrix and
it's on various conceptual levels which
is all completely fascinating but all
that we really care about right now is
that matrices are grids of values or a
list of lists for the programmers in the
room which I guess is everybody and when
you multiply two matrices together it
you kind of arranged them side by side
or diagonally to each other such that
you can read across the first row of the
first matrix and down the first column
of the second Matrix and get your answer
sort of at the intersection taking pairs
of elements you take sort of the
corresponding element of each one so top
one on the top first column left one on
the first row multiply those together
moving down and across multiply those
together add it to what you had keep
going and eventually you reach an answer
for that position since that was the top
row of a and the top color and the left
column of B this is the top left value
there's lots of reasons why this is cool
and interesting probably definitely
but basically you keep going and you do
the same thing for all of the cells all
the all the rows in column intersections
and you get something that looks like
this and this particular case I think
this is actually really ugly because
these numbers got huge this is
fortunately not a problem we have
because in weaving we're using binary
states so I'll show you what I mean
if you look at these weaving drafts
everything is either on or not right so
petal is pushed or it's not a petal is
tied to a Hetal frame or it's not a warp
is allocated to a frame or not and in
the final interlace Minh either the warp
or the weft is on top this is going to
really simplify our arithmetic because
we're going to be multiplying by zeros a
lot and then we're gonna be adding zeros
a lot and these things are very easy to
do so the way we're gonna get to the
actual fabric it turns out is that we're
gonna multiply the trebling times the
tie up times a transpose version of the
tie up and then we're gonna multiply
that times the threading so let's look
at the first multiplication operation
first right so as I said we actually
need a transpose version of the tie up
and this is just sort of due to how we
arrange them on the page in the first
place so we flip the tie up across a
diagonal in this particular case the
result is absolutely the same so taking
the first row in column we get some
filled in boxes and some that aren't
which we can kind of think of as of
course ones and zeros so that first row
and column we want 1 times 1 0 times 1
which is 0 0 times 0 which is still 0
and 0 times 0 which again is 0 and so
that of course works out to being 1
great we have a 1 in this position by
the way this isn't actually strictly
binary because you could be pushing down
more than one petal in a row again the
pedicle petals are physical things which
a weaver is pushing down with their
actual legs with which of which most
Weaver's have at most two but you can
you know push down more than one petal
with one leg it's sort of straddle
between them etc so what you'd actually
do in this case if you had more than one
petal down as you would threshold so in
the final arithmetic 0 would still mean
0
one or anything more would still mean
just one on so filling in the rest of
this matrix we end up with essentially
frames per time step and we're not at
the full fabric yet because we haven't
multiplied out to find out what each
frame means in terms of threads however
for what it's worth in this particular
case it already kind of looks like the
fabric doesn't it and that's because in
our case the threading is actually just
the identity matrix repeated across and
sorry I'll come back to that concept so
the fabric is actually just repeating
out the frames for the step and actually
there's a bit more hijinks because this
is transpose again because of the way we
laid it out but we get back there
somehow and I should actually have been
a diagonal flip but keno doesn't do that
so just use your imagination okay so
we've come we've come back full circle
on the draft that's that's what it means
that's what it looks like and there are
two takeaways I want you to think about
with with respect to this notation one
is it's all purely mechanical logic
right the way we're mechanically doing
selection is functionally an and
operation right the data passes through
if both of these things are true if the
pedal is down and the pedal is tied to a
frame pass through and if a warp is
associated with that frame pass it down
into the fabric right and it's it's I
find this very very satisfying on a
mechanical level level we're talking
about levers and petals and stuff and
we're passing data along the other take
away from a design perspective is that
all three components act together to
produce the final fabric in a way that
often feels kind of emergent so there's
a sense in which anything you wanted to
change in the tie up you could just
change in the treadle link instead
however there's a sense in which
altering a specific one gives you a way
to think about your design that the
other ones wouldn't so for example in
this case both the threading and the
treading are as I said they're the
identity matrix this is a really common
set up and actually is its own name we
call it like straight like a straight
draw or straight treading but and and
it's really common because a lot of
times when you have all three of these
ingredients coming together you want to
keep one or two of them
constant when you play with the third
one so to show you some sort of juicy
examples of that here are several
fabrics with the same threading and taya
but different treading alright so it's
really easy to switch the treadle in
Midway this is a decision you're making
at every time step and as I said you can
push more than one pedal in a row so you
see that in the bottom right example
there and sort of conversely here are
several fabrics with identical threading
and trebling but different taya
I've also swift switched to eight shafts
here to give you a little bit more
complexity view and this is a pointed to
threading and said of a instead of a
straight threading so physically
speaking changing the tie up is a bit
more work you do have to like untie
knots and retie knots but you can
totally still do it in the middle of
changing a weaving draft what you don't
want to do is change the threading right
so that kind of raises the question how
should you thread your loom right to get
maximal utility out of the threading
that you have and not want to change it
of course that depends on what kind of
thing you want to make right but just
thinking about sort of the theoretical
limits here how do you want to think
about threading a loom one way to think
about it is that you have as many unique
pattern rows as there are combinations
of frames available to you so - the
useless ones and I'll say what I mean
about that in a moment
so what do I mean right a unique pattern
row means that the two highlighted rows
here are actually the same right this
particular pattern happens to step
through its pattern rows in order and
then back again so it's sort of easy to
see where the unique ones are and this
pattern row is what happens when frames
1 3 5 & 8 are up depending on the type I
could have any combination of the frames
available right so for a to shaft loom I
have four possible combinations right
either shaft 1 is up or chef 2 is up or
neither of them is up or both of them
are up except that those last two are
kind of rubbish because if everything is
either up or down
you're not interlacing and if you're not
interlacing you're not making fabric
you're making a pile of yarn so
we try to avoid that in a four shaft
loom you get a lot more you get four
sixteen you get fourteen if you don't
count the bad ones and this is actually
kind of an overwhelming way to think
about weaving design especially you know
this is a four shaft loom some of these
floor looms go up to 24 shafts right
that possibility space gets quite large
but alright I said that somehow puzzle
pattern rows are kind of rubbish so what
if we started with something that we
know is good and think about subsetting
it from there good that is one way of
thinking about the central premise of a
style of weaving called network drafting
so this is a relatively new style of
frame weaving when I say relatively new
I mean it was inspired no I I do I
really do mean relatively new it was
inspired by this 1938 mass French
monograph by Brendon and Grisha
unfortunately this this monograph was
published in a run of 200 so they're
really hard to get your hands on but
this style of weaving really kicked off
later in the hand weaving world with the
introduction of hobbyist level CNC limbs
computer numerically controlled looms
right because it really shines on that
sort of 16 to 24 harness range which is
to say it's not the full jacquard the
industry had already switched to at this
point but it's a lot more shaft than a
normal person wants to think about in
their mind so in 1988 sort of with the
introduction of these home hobbyist
computer-controlled looms masau'u Rahzel
published an inspired work shaft weaving
and graph design oh wait I sorry this is
the one that was only printed as an
edition of 200 but fortunately for us
and wells published some notes
specifically intended for a weaving a
home hand-waving audience and this is
available as a free pdf that she put out
in 2000 and in between those two a lash
line wrote and published Network
drafting and introduction which is
currently available as a print on demand
and this is absolutely where I would
recommend that you start if you're
interested in this topic and I'll be
using some images from
her book later in this top so again 1938
publication of this math monograph and
then it was really picked up in earnest
with the availability of
computer-controlled handlooms which have
existed roughly alongside personal
computing and of course all of this is
absolutely an eyeblink
in the history of weaving right you know
this is the last 40 years on a twenty
five thousand twenty seven thousand year
scale right so this is super new I mean
so what is it what is it network
drafting the central idea of network
drafting and I'm going to say this a
couple more times to you is that any
cloth structure which can be woven on an
initial threading can also be woven on a
threading plotted on its associated
network okay so there are two at least
on film illegal terms unfamiliar terms
here initial threading and network an
initial threading is simply the very
most basic platonic unit of threading so
this is the one we've seen a couple of
times today it's the straight draw and
we've simply gone first thread first
frame second thread second frame etc so
straight draw aka the identity matrix
and if you did a straight tie up in
straight threading on the treadle hang
on this you would get a fabric that
looks exactly like this a 1x3 twill to
turn on initial into a network and I
want to everybody this has nothing to do
with like networks as any of us think of
them in this room but I will say that
the fiber artists got to the term first
so this is your fault not theirs so to
turn it into a network we repeat it
across all the frames we have available
to us and then all the threads that
we're using so if I have a fancy 16
shaft loom you know repeat it down and
in this case I'm showing it on 64 thread
so just actually a fairly small number
of threads but it's what fits on nicely
on this slide so the important thing to
note here is that the network is not a
threading after all every thread can
only be associated with one Hetal frame
so in an actual threading you'll only
see one filled in square per column so
what this is is in fact a space of
possible threadings what we've done is
we've constrained a given warp thread to
a choice of just four frames instead of
all 16
to pick which work which frame a given
work third will actually be in we draw a
pattern line like this which is going to
form the basis of the design so this is
just any sort of expressive line that
you feel like designing with and this
this is you know one of one of the major
points of creativity and network
drafting is picking this line in the
first place once you have the line sort
of superimposed over your network you
simply pick the legal threading position
that is closest to that line for a given
for a given warp thread well in this
case I'm picking a sense of closest
which actually means closest above and
I'm wrapping the pattern vertically when
that would have gone out of range over
the top so you can see that as the line
is close to the top of the network I've
come up to the bottom of it instead so
the overall actual threading looks like
the orange ones in this diagram and
because this is now a threading I can
put it into a draft and this is what it
would look like with a straight tie-up
and a straight travelling which is not
exciting and pretty rubbish as a fabric
because there are all these very long
stretches without a warp on top but I
brought it into this draft because I
want to illustrate a point a point is
this any cloth structure which can be
woven on an initial threading can also
be woven on a threading plotted on its
associated Network so what that means is
that I'm all it's always possible for me
to reconstitute the original the initial
fabric from this threading so if I have
a sort of fairly aggressive uniformly
distributed tie-up which now that you
mention it kind of looks like the
network I can get back to my 1 by 3
twill
what's changed though now is that I can
alter some areas of the fabric without
having to alter the others so if I sort
of say that the middle part of the
pattern is actually two threads to work
threads on top in a row instead of one
thread my pattern line magically
reimburses okay so why does this work
right I want to I want to return to the
idea of threading as picking subsets on
our little four shaft loom we only had
four possible subsets among which to
allocate our warps because of the magic
of tie-up and treading those four subs
can still create a variety of effects so
I've shown you here a one by three twill
a two by two twill and a three by one
coil you can do lots of other things
also with the same setting but even just
these three are actually I would say
pretty satisfying because if you have a
contrasting warp and weft like this you
functionally have a light medium and
dark gray the problem is on a four shaft
loom you can't do all of these at the
same time by which I mean sort of in the
same rows of fabric threads one in five
are through the same Hetal frame which
means that their fates are inextricably
mechanically linked however if you could
wrench those subsets apart you could
address the middle section separately
when you want it to of course you could
always address both sections together
because any structure which can be woven
on an initial threading can also be
woven on a threading plotted on its
associated network as we all very well
know now but you don't have to so here
are two areas being addressed
independently and then together so in
the top part I'm just doing a three by
one twill on sort of left and right
chunk of this draft and then in the
middle I'm doing a one by three twelve
on the middle and then in the bottom
part of the draft I'm doing both of them
together I'm sort of interlacing these
instructions into one line this idea by
the way the idea that you can have a
couple of different things happening on
one line and and interleave the
instructions themselves is broadly
called block drafting and that is a
popular concept in hand weaving in
general so that's how most shaft weaving
works for most kinds of patterns what's
unique about Network drafting in
particular is the idea that you can kind
of phase between the blocks because if
you've picked your blocks correctly you
can sort of be half in one block and
half in another so this is what leads to
the unique aesthetic of network drafting
and this is the part this is the payoff
part of the slide where I show you a
bunch of the talk where I show you a
bunch of beautiful networked drafts so
I've been showing you a lot of close-ups
right we've been looking at these like
sort of 30 thread wide things of course
actual weaving tends to
at least 10 threads per inch so you're
going to see more of a scale like this
in an actual fabric and network drafting
in particular is really known for these
graceful flowing curves and in this case
using the arc of the trebling sort of
alongside the right there I know it's
small but as I said we've zoomed out
quite a bit the arc of the treadle is
itself several times longer than the
actual width of the fabric so you're
getting these long curves over the
length of the fabric another major
aesthetic characteristic of network
drafting is harmonics or echoes and this
is something that if you're interested
in this this is actually what most of
the math and the math papers is about
but the you know sort of intuitively
speaking you can think of the fact that
because you're always phasing between
blocks sometimes you're picking up a
little bit of the next repeat of the
next block so you get these you get
these echoes you get these these
harmonic harmonics off of your main
motifs in network drafting and this is
yeah as I said this is sort of where the
math is in the math papers but it's also
something that hand Weaver's who are
trying deliberately to play with their
aesthetics will either try to really
bring out or kind of suppress so again
ascetic hallmark of network drafting and
here's an example of a network drafting
that is also doing sort of a more normal
block structure on the sides so you see
that the areas that the edges have just
these kind of like normal diagonals uh
and it's a little small and hard to see
but you can see that the threading like
up in the corners is just our normal
straight draw threading and then in the
middle they break apart and shift
together
and my final network drafting example
here has the same threading and tie-up
as each other there's three examples
here but it's different treading between
them and remember because treadle e can
be decided over the course of weaving
this very same fabric could shift
between being these three fairly differe
seaming patterns at the whim of the
weaver so I did say that at least
reading these sort of many shaft treadle
eggs can be hard to remember but that
internal logic that you're always sort
of going in these shifting twill
diagonals so like up and over and then
up and over and then up and over has a
rhythm of its own and because of that
this I think of this is a primary
example of hand weaving in the flow
state right it's an improvisational
process between the math setup that the
weaver has done in advance of weaving
and then the actual process of them
sitting at the loom
getting into the rhythm of what this
network looks like Network drafting and
I think I think network routing is truly
beautiful but my goal for this talk is
for you to be excited about weaving in
general and this is just a teeny tiny
piece of weaving so if for whatever
reason network drafting didn't get you
excited I want to show you a couple of
other cool weaving tricks so even just
with the same kind of loom we've been
talking about this like shaft loom idea
there's a whole bag of tricks around
weaving more than one layer of fabric at
the same time and then bringing them
above and below each other so you can
actually do this double weave on just
four shafts if you're clever
there's also double weave Network
drafting I I found a PDF three days it's
changing my life you can get very far
down this rabbit hole or if you just
like plain weave there's these
techniques where you're using color and
weave in which you're actually being
careful about the colors of the warp and
weft
to pull out these motor patterns even
with this is just a plain weave right
it's just that checkerboard pattern but
because the warps and wefts match each
other you're getting this emergent
stripy behavior okay if that's not
enough for you going further afield
how about triaxial weaving right this is
all done two subsets of
yarns were interlacing each other you
could have more you could have three you
could probably have more I don't know
that don't quote me on that I don't know
if that's true but three is definitely
possible and getting weirder in a
different direction
here's a goz weave in which the warps
themselves displace around each other so
each half twist is held in place by the
width and then paired with another half
twist back to its starting configuration
this is a really really simple version
of this technique and there's an entire
enormous Lea complicated subset of
Japanese weaving techniques that like
this is the building block for all so if
anybody's ever done sprang lace which is
a Nordic technique technique it's
arguably sort of a degenerate case of
this so like I said there is so much
weaving so much weaving to think about
but probably for some of you in the room
if you've never woven before this feels
may be still pretty abstract so I
actually want you to go out and play
with this and with that in mind
everybody gets a loom check under your
seat if under your seat is where you
store your laptop so I would like you to
go to this URL you know at your leisure
maybe you know we've got lunch coming up
maybe you could spend your whole lunch
playing with this little software
version of a loom so this is client-side
JavaScript you can click into little
thingies and get the draft to come out
also you can drag and drop in a weaving
draft and sort of the normal weaving
draft format which is totally a thing
because Weaver's are nerds and you can
download it and re upload it the same
way and this is kind of a virtual loom
right it's gonna give you this idea of
what your fabric would look like but I
want you to actually actually leave so
hit the the render frames and download
button and it's going to give you this
little cut pattern which you can then
actually cut out of cardboard and make
yourself a loom so this
but this particulate there's a million
ways you can make a loom this little
video is showing how to make a shoebox
loom which is you know exactly what it
sounds like I'm using some pieces of PVC
to hold my warp but you could use
whatever you could use pencils if you're
making it slightly smaller you know I I
have access to a laser cutter because
I'm lucky so I was able to laser cut my
little metal frames but you could
instead literally just exactly knife
them out of a piece of cereal box this
is all very legitimate ways of making
looms you don't even need the box right
you could tie your warps to your waste
on one end into a tree on the other end
that's called a backstrap loom by the
way and they're like tremendously
popular around the world because they're
extremely portable right you can take
your weaving with you wherever you just
need a little bit of tension and you
need a way to make a shed yeah this is
the tedious part remember I was like you
have to pull all the threads through all
the holes that's why we sped up the
footage
but the point I'm trying to make here is
that people have been doing this for
actual ever um and you can to very
easily weather virtually or in actual
reality I really encourage you to go out
and do this thing and I have I have I
have this one with me so you can come
play with it at lunch the good parts
coming up oh yeah here it is oh yeah
[Applause]
okay thank you very much that's been
weaving
and I do have two and a half minutes and
I do have two and a half questions three
and a half questions uh uh so I do the
easy ones first what does a triaxial
loom look like they as far as I know
don't exist but I could be totally wrong
you should look this up on the internet
so that wasn't actually an easy one but
it's a question for you what did I use
for the diagrams most of the weaving
drafts I just made in that little
JavaScript thing probably obviously and
everything else was made an illustrator
how would you extend the binary matrix
needs to represent different thread
colors I have no idea I think that
probably some people in this room might
have ideas about that gosh I mean I
don't know some sort of tuple or
something y'all are the computer
scientists cool you didn't think about
that alright thank you
[Applause]